a new photo of kristen stewart as
princess diana and spencer was just
released
and their resemblance is wild i'm really
excited
on thursday the upcoming princess diana
biopic spencer released a new image of
kristen
playing diana posing with a soft smile
and wearing a replica of diana's
sapphire engagement ring
the plaid red and green blazer and white
turtleneck the actress is wearing
also resembles an outfit diana wore back
in 1989
this is the second image the film has
shared the first one was released back
in january
check out kristin as diana rocking an
iconic
look the royal war in 1986 when she
visited a spinal injuries unit in
england
i was so into it in june neon the studio
behind the film
announced that the biopic was set to be
made for a fall 2021 release
and the film will highlight princess
diana aka diana spencer
in december 1991 as she faces the end of
her 15-year marriage to prince charles
while spending christmas at queen
elizabeth's estate
this is a really um kind of like poetic
uh really internalized
imagining kind of like a really heavy
like maybe the heaviest like three days
time
before she does something as gnarly as
leaving the royal family back in
november kristen told et how she's
preparing for the role
i'm just sort of like reading everything
that i can and then forgetting it
because
it's kind of a really like internal
internalized story and although we don't
know how the royals feel about the
making of the movie
we do know that they are no stranger to
their lives playing out publicly
we all know what the british press can
be like and it was destroying my mental
health i was like this is toxic
yeah so i did what any husband and what
only father would do
earlier this month diana's youngest son
prince harry and wife meghan markle
made headlines after they sat down with
oprah winfrey to share why they decided
to step back from their lives as royals
you can understand this if in your own
office
or in your own family somebody is saying
things about you that are not true
and how hurtful that is during the
interview megan and harry made a claim
that certain members of the royal family
were concerned over the potential skin
color of their son archie before he was
born
shortly after the palace responded with
the statement that they take claims of
racism very seriously
and are launching an internal
investigation according to reports
released on monday
the palace is now considering hiring a
diversity czar
but royal expert katie nickel tells et
it has nothing to do with harry and
meghan's interview
i think of course a lot of people will
see this story and think that this is a
reactive
move that this is the palace uh wanting
to take
a positive step against these claims of
racism within the institution but
it has been pointed out to me that this
search for a
diversity star or a chief of diversity
at the palace is something they've been
looking at for
some time but i think the point is that
this is now being
put out in the public domain
deliberately
after the palace has been accused of
being
racist essentially has found itself at
the center of a racist row